हेलो हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ़ ऑल वेरी
गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल। तो सबसे पहले मुझे यह
बताइए सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है?
बताइए जल्दी से सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे
रही है? या नहीं सुनाई दे रही है? आई एम
ऑडीबल गाइज़। लाउड एंड क्लियर? जल्दी से
चैट में बताइए।
सुनाई दे रही है? बिल्कुल
थैंक यू गाइस। तो अगेन सभी को गुड
मॉर्निंग सॉरी गुड इवनिंग नमस्ते या अदर
कंट्री से हो तो गुड मॉर्निंग। तो
क्या हो गया सर? मैं कांटेक्ट सेंटर में
काम करता हूं। डेवलपमेंट
करता हूं। डेवलपमेंट आपके प्रीवियस सेशन
बहुत हेल्पफुल था। तो थैंक यू अगर आपको
मेरा प्रीवियस सेशन काफी हेल्पफुल लगा तो
आई एम आल्सो वेरी हैप्पी। तो
बट अच्छी बात है सीखिए।
तो तो आज का सेशन बिल्कुल स्टार्ट करने से
पहले जस्ट 1 मिनट का टाइम लेते हैं। बाकी
स्टूडेंट्स को ज्वाइन होने देते हैं। तब
तक के लिए
लाइक कीजिए। सब्सक्राइब कर लीजिए। एटलीस्ट
जिसने चैनल को सब्सक्राइब नहीं कीजिए किया
है और जिसने अभी तक कमेंट नहीं किया तो
एटलीस्ट कमेंट तो कीजिए कि अच्छा या बुरा
बताइए जल्दी से इसमें कोई इशू नहीं है तो
अगर कोई किसी का डाउट है तो मुझसे पूछ
सकता है नेक्स्ट 1 मिनट में क्योंकि उसके
बाद हम सेशन को स्टार्ट कर देंगे और आई
प्रॉमिस आज के सेशन को बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग
बनाने वाला हूं। ज्यादा लंबा सेशन नहीं
लेंगे क्योंकि सबके लिए नया टॉपिक है। तो
मैं जितना भी पढ़ाऊंगा आपको बहुत अच्छा
पढ़ाऊंगा।
देयर आर ओनली वन फाइव स्टूडेंट ओनली। तो
मैं थोड़ा सा और वेट करते हैं कि कितने
स्टूडेंट और ज्वाइन करेंगे क्योंकि अभी तो
जितनी भी क्लास आएंगी सब पर मैं सोच रहा
हूं कि रिस्पांस अच्छा होना चाहिए आप
लोगों का
क्योंकि प्रीवियस क्लास में मैंने आपको
बताया था कि हम क्या सीखने वाले हैं और आज
देखना हम कैसे शुरुआत करेंगे। आज बेसिक से
स्टार्ट करेंगे। बिल्कुल ही कोई आपको पता
है कि जब सचिन सर पढ़ाते हैं तो बेसिक से
पढ़ाते हैं।
तो जल्दी से
बोलिए स्टूडेंट्स को ज्वाइन करने के लिए
जो आपके साथ डेली जो क्लासेस में आते हैं।
पता नहीं आज क्यों नहीं आए अभी तक। वी आर
लाइव फ्रॉम लास्ट 3 मिनट।
तब तक किसी का कोई सवाल है मुझसे पूछना
चाहोगे?
कोई सवाल नहीं है। मुझे एक चीज तो देखा कि
जगत गुरु जी हमेशा मेरी क्लास में आते
हैं। कभी मेरी क्लास मिस नहीं करते। तो
मेरी तरफ से बहुत बड़ा थैंक यू आपको कि आप
हमेशा मेरी क्लास को ज्वाइन करते हो। तो
मुझे बहुत अच्छा लगता है। कुछ जो
स्टूडेंट्स हैं मुझे नाम याद है कि वो
कंटीन्यूसली मेरी सिंगल क्लास उन्होंने
मिस नहीं की है। कभी भी जगत गुरु जी वन ऑफ
देम।
आपका असली नाम क्या है? मुझे बता सकते हो
इफ पॉसिबल।
मुझे नहीं लगता स्टूडेंट्स आने वाले हैं
क्योंकि
वह अपनी जिंदगी में बहुत बिजी हैं। उन्हें
सीखने की फुर्सत नहीं है। वह सीखना नहीं
चाहते।
चलो हम सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं। फिर ओके
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। जितने भी स्टूडेंट
हैं उन्हीं से स्टार्ट कर लेते हैं। जिनको
मिस करना वो मिस कर लेंगे।
नाउ हम स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं वप में वॉइस
ओवर इंटरनेट प्रोटोकॉल के अंदर। उसके
बेसिक के बारे में स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं।
मैं बेसिकली इसको चैप्टर वन ही बोलना
चाहूंगा। आप चाहो तो बीच-बीच में चेंज कर
सकते हो। बट मैं इसको चैप्टर वन बोल रहा
हूं। बेसिक से बिल्कुल हम बेसिक से
स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं। तो नाउ
इन वाइप सिस्टम दी एक्चुअल अंडरलाइन
प्रोटोकॉल सच एज शिप आरटीपी एंड आरटीसीपी
आर क्विट कॉम्प्लेक्स एंड देयर इंटरनल
वर्किंग गो वेरी डीप
मतलब वेब के जो वेब के जो भी एक्चुअल
प्रोटोकॉल्स होते हैं जैसे आपका एसआईपी हो
गया आपका आरटीपी हो गया या आरटीसीपी हो
गया वो काफी ज्यादा कॉम्प्लेक्स होते हैं
और जिनका जो इंटरनल वर्किंग होता है वह
काफी ज्यादा डीप में होता है और इसलिए इस
क्लास में जितनी भी क्लासेस मैं आपको
पढ़ाने वाला हूं वब सिस्टम के अंदर या वब
के वशिप एंड टेस्टिंग से रिलेटेड या वॉइप
सिक्योरिटी से रिलेटेड मैं सिंपली आपको हर
एक चीज को सिंपली का सिंपलीफाई करके
समझाऊंगा। आपको सिंपलीफाई करके चीजों को
बिल्कुल ज्यादा डीप में नहीं जाएंगे या
ज्यादा ऊपर ऊपर से नहीं जाएंगे। मतलब आपको
चीजें समझ में आए। हर चीज को सिंपलीफाई
करके समझाऊंगा। वी विल नॉट डाइव इंटू
अननेसेसरी इंजीनियरिंग लेवल डिटेल्स। वी
विल ओनली फोकस ऑन व्हाट मैटर्स फॉर
ट्रैफिक एनालिसिस एंड सिक्योरिटी
एनालिसिस। मतलब मेरे कहने का यह है कि हम
अन सॉरी हम अननेसेसरी डेप्थ में नहीं
जाएंगे। हम सिर्फ वो चीज कवर करेंगे जो
किसी भी ट्रैफिक एनालिसिस और सिक्योरिटी
एनालिसिस के पर्सपेक्टिव से इंपॉर्टेंट
है। और हम दो चीजों पर फोकस करेंगे। वी
विल फोकस ऑन टू थिंग्स। सबसे पहली ट्रैफिक
एनालिसिस पर्सपेक्टिव। दूसरा सिक्योरिटी
एनालिसिस पर्सपेक्टिव। तो हम सबसे पहले
ट्रैफिक एनालिसिस परस्पेक्टिव से क्या चीज
देखने वाले हैं? तो हाउ डस ए वॉइप कॉल लुक
एट द नेटवर्क पैकेट लेवल? व्हिच पो्स आर
यूज्ड? व्हिच प्रोटोकॉल्स अपीयर? व्हाट
टाइप ऑफ ट्रैफिक इज जनरेटेड ड्यूरिंग अ
कॉल? मतलब यह है कि नेटवर्क पैकेट लेवल पर
वॉइप कॉल्स एक्चुअली कैसी दिखाई देती हैं?
कौन से पो्स, कौन से प्रोटोकॉल्स और किस
टाइप का ट्रैफिक जनरेट होता है? यह सारी
चीजें हम क्या करने वाले हैं? देखने वाले
हैं। अगर हम बात करें कि सिक्योरिटी
पर्सपेक्टिव से हम क्या देखने वाले हैं कि
हाउ कैन अटैकर एक्सपर्ट वाइप सिस्टम, हाउ
डू कॉल स्पिंग, कॉल इंटरसेप्शन, डोर्स
अटैक्स एंड टोल फ्रॉड हैपंस? या एंड हाउ
डू डिफेंडर सिक्योर वॉइप
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर्स कि अटैकर्स वप को कैसे
एक्सप्लइट करते हैं? कैसे कॉल स्पिंग जैसी
चीजें या कॉल इंटरसेप्शन या डोस बोलो या
टूल फ्रॉड जैसी चीजें होती हैं। एंड हाउ
डेवलपर्स
हाउ डिफेंडर्स सिक्योर वाइप
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर और डिफेंडर्स वाइप सिस्टम
को कैसे सिक्योर करते हैं? यह सारी चीजें
हम क्या करने वाले हैं? सीखने वाले हैं या
चीजें हम देखने वाले हैं। ओके? तो नेक्स्ट
और मैं एक चीज और बता देता हूं कि हम ओनली
रेलेवेंट कांसेप्ट कवर करने वाले हैं। जो
पूरे प्रोटोकॉल की जो इंजीनियरिंग लेवल है
जो उसकी जो इंटरनल आर्किटेक्चर है
इंजीनियरिंग लेवल पर मैं वो बिल्कुल भी
डिलीवर नहीं करने वाला। मैं जस्ट जो
रेलेवेंट जो कांसेप्ट है हमारे सिक्योरिटी
पर्सपेक्टिव या ट्रैफिक एनालिसिस
पर्सपेक्टिव या पेन टेस्टिंग पर्सपेक्टिव
सिर्फ वही कवर करने वाले हैं। उससे ज्यादा
हम डीप में नहीं जाने वाले। यह चीज़ मैं
आपको पहले ही क्लियर कर देता हूं। तो अभी
मैं आपको हाई लेवल ओवरव्यू देता हूं कि एक
एग्जांपल से समझते हैं। फॉर एग्जांपल्स कि
कॉलर ए और कॉलर टू ये क्या है कि Google
मीट या zूम मीट के थ्रू क्या करते हैं?
अपने आप को मीट में मीटिंग में ज्वॉइ कर
लिया और बात कर रहे हैं। तो क्या होता है?
जब कॉलर ए कॉलर बी से बात करना चाहता है।
तो क्या होता है? बीच में एक इंटरमीडिएट
सर्वर होता है। डायरेक्टली कभी भी कॉलर ए
से कॉलर बी के पास कभी भी कॉल नहीं जाती।
बीच में क्या होता है? एक सर्वर होता है
जो मीडिया मीडिएटर का काम करता है। तो
जैसे आप बोला आपने कॉलर ए ने क्या किया?
कॉलर बी से बात करनी है। तो उसने माइक में
बोला हेलो या जो पहला जो शब्द बोला तो
आपकी जो ऑडियो स्ट्रीम है वो ऑडियो
स्ट्रीम किसके पास जाएगी? जो बीच में
इंटरमीडिएट सर्वर है जिसको हम मीडिया
सर्वर भी बोल सकते हैं। उसके पास जाएगी।
उससे फिर जो मीडिया सर्वर है आपके कॉलर बी
के पास उस वॉइस को ट्रांसफर करेगा। समझ
में आया? मतलब अगर कॉलर ए कॉलर बी से बात
कर रहा तो कितनी ऑडियो स्ट्रीम बनने वाली
है? दो। वहीं पर अगर कॉलर बी को कॉलर ए से
बात करनी है मतलब कॉलर बी को ए से बात
करनी है तो क्या होगा? तब भी आप उसकी जो
ऑडियो स्ट्रीम है जो बात कर रहा है जो
वॉइस डाटा है या जिसको हम बोल सकते हैं
वॉइस स्ट्रीम है। वॉइस स्ट्रीम है या वॉइस
डाटा स्ट्रीम्स है वह सारी चीज़ सबसे पहले
किसके पास जाएंगी? बीच में जो सर्वर है
जिसको मीडिया सर्वर भी बोल सकते हैं। ये
आपको पता चल जाएगा कि बीच में कौन होता
है। बिल्कुल डिटेल में आपको पता चल जाएगा।
फिर उसके बाद कॉलर ए के पास वो आवाज
पहुंचती है। तो इस तरीके से आपका नॉर्मल
कम्युनिकेशन काम करता है किसके अंदर? वप
के केस में। चाहे आप वो टेलीफोन यूज कर
रहे हो, चाहे आप WhatsApp यूज कर रहे हो,
चाहे आप ZM मीटिंग यूज कर रहे हो, चाहे आप
Google मीटिंग यूज कर रहे हो, वो ऐसे काम
करती है। तो कहने का मतलब कि अगर कॉलर ए
और कॉलर बी दोनों आपस में बात कर रहे हैं
तो टोटल चार ऑडियो स्ट्रीम होगी। जस्ट एक
बार में बात करने पर जैसे हेलो बोला तो
वही अगर वहीं पर अगर चार लोग आपस में बात
कर रहे हैं तो मतलब कितनी ऑडियो स्ट्रीम
होगी? सिक्स। ओब्ली एक बार बोलने की बात
है। ऐसा नहीं कि आप कंटीन्यूसली बोल रहे
हो, बात कर रहे हो तो सोचो कि बहुत ज्यादा
ऑडियो स्ट्रीम जनरेट होती है जो मीडिया
सर्वर के थ्रू जाती है या जो बीच में जो
इंटरमीडिएट सर्वर उसके थ्रू जाती है। तो
ये एक हाई ओवरव्यू था। तो मैं आपको और
थोड़ा सा और डीप में जाते हैं। इसको थोड़ा
सा और डिटेल में इसको एक्सप्लोर करता हूं
कि यह तो मैंने बिल्कुल ऊपर ऊपर से बताया।
थोड़ा सा और आगे चलते हैं। इसमें एक और यह
एक देखिए कि हम जब वब कम्युनिकेशन की बात
करते हैं तो जब हम वप को बिल्कुल हाई लेवल
पर देखें तो व हमेशा दो सेपरेट चैनल यूज़
करता है। कौन सा? एक तो सिग्नलिंग चैनल
यूज़ करता है। दूसरा मीडिया चैनल यूज़
करता है। क्योंकि जो कॉलर ए है कभी भी वह
कॉलर पी के साथ डायरेक्टली कम्युनिकेट
नहीं कर सकता। तो उसको क्या करना पड़ेगा?
सबसे पहले वो सिग्नलिंग चैनल का यूज़ करता
है। उसके बाद यह क्या करता है? सिग्नल
चैनल सिग्नलिंग चैनल क्या करता है? एक
प्रकार से एचटीटीपी की तरह ही है। यह पूरा
अपना हैंडशक कंप्लीट करता है। हैंडशक
कंप्लीट करने के बाद क्या होता है कि जब
वहां पर आपको 200 ओके सिग्नल मिल जाता है।
देन ओनली क्या होता है कि आपका जो मीडिया
चैनल है वो एक्टिवेट होता है और मीडिया
चैनल के थ्रू आपकी बात जाती है कॉलर बी के
पास। सेम कॉलर किसके पास होती है? आपके
कॉलर ए के केस में। अगर कॉल कॉलर बी के
केस में। कॉलर बी को भी कॉलर ए से बात
करनी है तो सबसे पहले क्या होगा उसका
सिग्नलिंग चैनल के थ्रू सिग्निंग चैनलिंग
में क्या है सबसे पहले उसके जो भी
सिग्नल्स हैं ये जो भी मैसेजेस है व शिप
सर्वर के पास जाती हैं इनके बीच में
कम्युनिकेशन इस्टैब्लिश होता है उसके बाद
फिर मीडिया सर्वर का यूज़ किया जाता है
मीडिया चैनल का यूज़ किया जाता है जिसको
हम आरटीपी सर्वर बोलते हैं उसको शिप सर्वर
भी बोल सकते हैं पीबीx सर्वर भी बोल सकते
हैं उसके थ्रू आपका कम्युनिकेशन होता है
यह जस्ट मैंने हाई ओवरव्यू दिया है
बिल्कुल ऊपर ऊपर से मैंने आपको बताया और
एक और इंपॉर्टेंट बात यहां पर क्या है कि
आपको समझने की बात यह है कि जो वेब
कम्युनिकेशन है वेब कम्युनिकेशन में
सिग्नलिंग और मीडिया चैनल कभी भी एक चैनल
पे नहीं होंगे हमेशा अलग-अलग होंगे। ये
दोनों बिल्कुल अलग-अलग होंगे क्योंकि हर
एक दोनों का जो बोल सकते हैं रोल अलग है।
दोनों की रिस्पांसिबिलिटी अलग है। दोनों
का काम अलग है। इसलिए कभी भी यह एक चैनल
पे नहीं होंगे। सिग्नलिंग चैनल और मीडिया
चैनल दोनों के दोनों हमेशा अलग होंगे। तो
यह चीज मैं आपको बता दी। तो नाउ तो व
ऑलवेज यूज टू सेपरेट चैनल्स। तो व आपका
हमेशा दो सेपरेट चैनल का यूज करता है।
जैसे मैंने आपको बताया एक तो सिग्नलिंग
चैनल होता है। दूसरा आपका मीडिया चैनल
होता है। तो सबसे पहले हम बात करते हैं
सिग्नलिंग चैनल की। तो दिस दिस चैनल इज
रिस्पांसिबल फॉर कॉल सेटअप एंड कंट्रोल
एंड नॉट एक्चुअल वॉइस डाटा। जो यह चैनल
होता है किसके लिए रिस्पांसिबल होता है?
आपकी कॉल सेटअप के लिए और या कॉल को
कंट्रोल करने के लिए होता है। आपका जो भी
एक्चुअल वॉइस डाटा जो भी आप बात करते हो
उसके लिए रिस्पांसिबल नहीं होता है। लेकिन
उसके लिए इनिशियल लेवल पे काम करता है।
नाउ सिग्नलिंग सिंपलीफाई मींस सिंपली मींस
सिग्नलिंग का मतलब क्या है? स्टार्टिंग ए
कॉल, रिंगिंग, एक्सेप्टिंग द कॉल, एंडिंग
द कॉल, सेंडिंग नोटिफिकेशन, सेंडिंग
इंस्ट्रक्शंस, मैनेजिंग कॉल फॉर
मैनेजिंग मैनेजिंग कॉल फ्लो थ्रू सर्वर्स।
तो सिग्नलिंग का मतलब क्या है? कि जैसे कि
कॉल स्टार्ट हो रही है, कॉल रिंग हो रही
है, कॉल एक्सेप्ट हो रही है, कॉल एंड हो
गई है, कॉलर ए, कॉलर बी को इनवाइट भेज रहा
है। और नेटवर्क सर्वर कॉल फ्लो मैनेज कर
रहा है। ये सारी चीजें किसके अंदर आती है?
सिग्नलिंग के थ्रू होती है। बेसिकली क्या
होता है जो सिग्नलिंग है वॉइस डेटा के साथ
वो डील नहीं करता। वो सिर्फ डील करता है
कंट्रोल मैसेज के साथ। और एक और चीज होती
है कि जो सिग्नलिंग है सिग्नलिंग के लिए
सबसे मोस्ट पॉपुलर एक प्रोटोकॉल्स होता है
जिसका नाम है शिप। दी मोस्ट पॉपुलर
प्रोटोकॉल इन केस ऑफ सिग्निलिंग प्रोटोकॉल
इज कॉल्ड शिप सेशन इनिशिएशन प्रोटोकॉल जो
रिस्पांसिबल होता है। इसके बारे में हम
आगे डिटेल्स में पढ़ेंगे। तो नाउ तो
एग्जांपल ऑफ सिग्नलिंग एक्शन जैसे द कॉल
इज स्टार्टिंग। कॉल स्टार्ट हो रही है और
दी फोन इज रिंगिंग। फोन रिंग कर रहा है। द
कॉल हैज़ बीन एक्सेप्टेड। फोन आपने उठा
लिया है। कॉल हैज़ बीन एंडेड। कॉल कट हो गई
है या कॉलर ए ने इनवाइट मैसेज भेजा कॉलर
बी को। यह क्या होता है? मैं सबको
बताऊंगा। सब कुछ बताऊंगा। शिप सर्वर इज़
फॉरवर्डिंग एंड मैनेजिंग द कॉल। कॉल फ्लो।
जो शिप सर्वर है, वह क्या कर रहा है? कॉल
फ्लो को भेज रहा है। तो, दीज़ आर कंट्रोल
मैसेजेस नॉट ऑडियो मैसेज। यह सारे के सारे
क्या आपके? कंट्रोल मैसेजेस के अंदर आते
हैं। ऑडियो मैसेजेस नहीं होते। तो वी कैन
से दैट कि जो आपका जो सिग्नलिंग चैनल है
वो वॉइस को छोड़कर बाकी जो इंस्ट्रक्शंस
हैं या कॉल कंट्रोल मैसेज है उन सबको
हैंडल करता है। या दूसरी सिंपल भाषा में
हम क्या बोलें कि जितने भी कॉल्स के प्रति
जो कॉल्स के अकॉर्डिंग जो रूल्स हैं जो भी
रूल्स अप्लाई होते हैं कॉल्स के लिए या जो
भी इंस्ट्रक्शंस पास की जाती हैं। कैसे
कॉल होगी, कैसे कॉल नहीं होगी, कैसे
कम्युनिकेशन, कैसे फ्लो होगा या जो भी
नोटिफिकेशंस है उसको कंट्रोल करने वाली
चीजें हैं उनको मैनेज करने का काम किसका?
आपके सिग्नलिंग प्रोटोकॉल का काम है। यह
चीज सबने समझ में आ गई कि सिग्नलिंग
प्रोटोकॉल होता क्या है? सबको समझ में आ
गया? व्हाट इज सिग्नलिंग प्रोटोकॉल?
जल्दी से चैट में बताओ जल्दी से यस या नो
सिग्नलिंग प्रोटोकॉल सबको समझ में आ गया
फिर आगे बढ़ेंगे हम
ओके गुड तो एक एग्जांपल लेते हैं
एग्जांपल लेते हैं फॉर एग्जांपल जैसे ये
एग्जांपल है कि कॉल स्टार्ट कैसे होती है।
सोचो कि जो ए है कॉलर ए है कॉलर ए ने कॉलर
बी को कॉल लगाई। कॉलर ए ने कॉलर बी को कॉल
लगाई। तो इस इस प्रोसेस को हैंडल किया
जाता है किसके द्वारा? सिग्नलिंग चैनल के
द्वारा। जो भी सिग्नल चैलेंज है इस
प्रोसेस को हैंडल करता है। और एक और चीज
बता देता हूं जो वॉइप कॉल है वो
डायरेक्टली कभी भी ए टू बी नहीं जाएगी।
कभी भी डायरेक्टली ऐसा नहीं कि ए ने बी को
कॉल किया और बी के पास पहुंच जाएगी। कभी
भी डायरेक्टली नहीं जाएगी। बीच में एक
सर्वर होता है। उस सर्वर को हम क्या बोलते
हैं? शिप सर्वर भी बोल सकते हैं। पीबीएक्स
सर्वर भी कह सकते हैं। कुछ भी कह सकते
हैं। तो फॉर एग्जांपल ए जो कॉलर ए है सेंड
एन इनवाइट मैसेज। उसने क्या किया? इनवाइट
मैसेज भेजा। किसको? कॉलर बी को। बट वो
डायरेक्टली नहीं भेजा। तो इनवाइट सबसे
पहले किसके पास जाएगा? जो एसआईपी सर्वर है
शिप सर्वर या जो पीबीx सर्वर है बीच में
उसके पास जाएगा। ठीक है? सर्वर ने क्या
किया? सर्वर ने उस मैसेज को फॉरवर्ड कर
दिया बी के पास। उस सर्वर ने क्या कर
दिया? उस मैसेज को बी के पास फॉरवर्ड कर
दिया। उसके बाद क्या है? जब
व्हेन बी रिसीव द इनवाइट मैसेज बी फोन
स्टार्ट रिंग। जैसे ही क्या हुआ कि जो
आपका कॉलर भी था कॉलर को जैसे ही इनवाइट
मैसेज मिला रिसीव हुआ तो उसके एंड पर जो
भी टेलीफोन था उसमें रिंग बजना स्टार्ट हो
गई। और वहीं पर पैरेलली जिसने कॉल किया था
आपने नोटिस किया होगा वहां पर एक
नोटिफिकेशन टाइप का आता है रिंगिंग कॉलिंग
और रिंगिंग तो रिंगिंग तो मतलब यह तभी आता
है जब दूसरे एंड पर जो कॉलर जिसके पास
आपने कॉल किया है उसके पास अगर रिंग चल
रही है तभी वह मैसेज आपको देखने को मिल
रहा है लिंगिंग यह आपने नोटिस किया होगा
कभी भी आप WhatsApp कॉल करते हो या कभी भी
और भी बहुत सारी कॉल है जिसमें आपको यह
नोटिफिकेशन देखने को मिलता है या टेलीफोन
देखोगे टेलीफोन फोन में भी यही देखने को
मिलता है कि रिंगिंग वहीं पर एक
नोटिफिकेशन छोटा सा रिंगिंग
यह चीज वहीं पर देखने को मिलती है। तो इस
तरीके से क्या कॉल कॉलिंग स्टार्ट हो गई
और उसके बाद क्या होता है? जैसे ही फोन
एक्सेप्ट कर लेता है। जैसे ही उसने कॉल
उठाया अह कॉलर बी ने तो व्हेन बी एक्सेप्ट
द जो शिप सर्वर है यह क्या करता है जो शिप
सर्वर को 200 ओके मैसेज भेज देता है और जो
क्या होता है कि 200 ओके मैसेज भेजने के
बाद जो 200 ओके मैसेज शिप सर्वर किसको भेज
देता है कॉलर ए के पास जो शिप सर्वर है
कॉलर ए के पास 200 मैसेज भेज देता है तो
इस तरीके से क्या होता है आपका कंप्लीट
हैंडशक कंप्लीट हो जाता है और यह हैंडशक
कितना डिटेल्स में है मैं आपको बताने वाला
हूं पहले ओवरव्यू देखेंगे। उसके बाद पैकेट
लेवल पे देखेंगे। एनालाइज करना देखेंगे।
सब कुछ देखेंगे। उसके बाद यह आपका
सिंगलिंग प्रोटोकॉल सिग्निलिंग चैनल ऐसे
काम करता है। सब कुछ सिग्नल चैनल के थ्रू
हो गया। और एक बार जब यह 200 ओके मिल गया
कॉलर बी ने एक्सेप्ट कर लिया। उसके बाद जो
आपका वॉइस डाटा है, आपकी जो भी बात होगी,
वह सब कुछ किसके थ्रू होगी? मीडिया चैनल
के थ्रू। तो नेक्स्ट
मीडिया चैनल क्या होता है? वंस द कॉल इज
एक्सेप्टेड द रियल कम्युनिकेशन बिगेन। जब
एक बार क्या होता है कि एक बार कॉल
एक्सेप्ट कर लिया तब असली कम्युनिकेशन
स्टार्ट होता है। दिस चैनल कैरीज़ द
एक्चुअल वॉइस डाटा यूजिंग आरटीपी रियल
टाइम ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल। क्या होता है कि
जो एक्चुअल जो आपका वॉइस डाटा है वो किसके
थ्रू जाता है? आपके मीडिया चैनल के थ्रू।
मीडिया चैनल के बाद कौन सा सर्वर होता है?
आरटीपी सर्वर। रियल टाइम ट्रांसफर
प्रोटोकॉल एक सर्वर होता है। उसके थ्रू
आपका डाटा जाता है। जहां पर ओनली इस चैनल
पे क्या होता है? ओनली ओनली क्या होता है?
आपके जो वॉइस पैकेट है वो ट्रैवल करते
हैं। नो सिग्नलिंग मैसेज आर इंक्लूडेड
कंटीन्यूअस आरटीपी स्ट्रीम्स रियल टाइम
ऑडियो पैकेज और हाई फ्रीक्वेंसी पैकेट
एक्सचेंज। वहां पर क्या होता है आपके हाई
फ्रीक्वेंसी। बेसिकली वी कैन से दैट जो भी
आप बात करते हो चाहे वीडियो कॉल करो ऑडियो
कॉल करो। जो भी आप वॉइस डाटा है आपका जो
ट्रैवल करता है वह इस चैनल में ट्रैवल
करेगा। सिर्फ वॉइस पैकेज की बात हो रही
है। यहां पर कोई भी सिग्नलिंग मैसेज नहीं
है। अभी तक जो मैंने बताया ना कॉल कॉल को
एक्सेप्ट करना, कॉल के रिंग बजना, उसके
कॉल को टर्मिनेट होना उस टाइप के कोई भी
मैसेज यहां पर डील नहीं किए जाते। तो उसके
बाद क्या होता है? जब एक बार कॉल एंड
होगी। चाहे कॉलर एंड करे या कॉलर बी एंड
करे। कोई भी अगर कॉलर कॉल को एंड करता है
तो उसके बाद फिर से क्या होता है जो
सिग्नलिंग चैनल है वह एक्टिवेट हो जाता
है। उसके बाद क्या होता एक बाय मैसेज आता
है। कॉल टर्मिनेट होती है। एकनॉलेजमेंट
दोनों साइड होता है और चैनल क्लोज कर दिया
जाता है। आफ्टर द बाय इज प्रोसेस जो
मीडिया चैनल है उसको भी क्लोज कर दिया
जाता है। तो यह रहा आपका सिग्नलिंग
प्रोटोकॉल प्लस में आपका मीडिया चैनल सॉरी
सिग्नलिंग चैनल और मीडिया चैनल दोनों ऐसे
काम करते हैं। यह चीज सबको समझ में आई?
यहां तक क्लियर? कैसी चीजें काम हुई है?
एवरीवन यहां तक सब कुछ क्लियर है सबको?
बताइए सबको यहां तक क्लियर है?
जल्दी से बताओ जल्दी-जल्दी चैट में अभी
आगे और इंटरेस्ट आने वाला है।
जल्दी बताओ जल्दी
बस ओनली इतना ही दो से तीन लोगों को समझ
में आया। बाकी लोग क्या कर रहे हो?
नाउ अभी बात करते हैं सिग्नलिंग
प्रोटोकॉल्स के बारे में। अब इस अभी तक
हमने क्या देखा जो सिग्नलिंग चैनल था उसके
बारे में बात की कि वो क्या था? सिग्नलिंग
चैनल जहां पर कर्ल इनिशिएट होता है, रिंग
होती है, एक्सेप्ट होता है और टर्मिनेट
होता है। या ये था आपका सिग्नलिंग चैनल।
अब हम सिग्नलिंग चैनल को इंप्लीमेंट करने
के लिए जो भी मल्टीपल प्रोटोकॉल्स होते
हैं, जो भी मल्टीपल प्रोटोकॉल्स यूज़ होते
हैं, उनके बारे में डिस्कस करने वाले हैं।
क्योंकि सिग्नलिंग अपने आप में क्या है?
एक जेनेरिक कांसेप्ट है। लेकिन इस
कांसेप्ट को रियल वर्ल्ड में इंप्लीमेंट
करने के लिए भी क्या होता है? जो अलग-अलग
कंपनीज़ हैं या आपके जो भी स्टैंडर्ड बॉडीज
हैं, उन्होंने डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट सिग्नलिंग
प्रोटोकॉल्स बनाए हैं। अभी हम किस में बात
करने वाले हैं? आज। टुडे वी विल डिस्कस ऑन
टॉप थ्री सिग्नलिंग प्रोटोकॉल्स दैट हैव
बीन हिस्टोरिकली एंड प्रैक्टिकली
इंप्लीमेंटेड। ओके? तो तो जो टॉप थ्री जो
सिग्नलिंग प्रोटोकॉल थे जो हिस्टोरिकली और
प्रैक्टिकली इंपॉर्टेंट है उनके बारे में
बताते हैं। कौन-कौन से थे आपका शिप था
H323
और एससीसीपी। तो वन बाय वन इसके बारे में
थोड़ा इंट्रोडक्शन करते हैं। ओवरव्यू लेते
हैं कि सेशन इनिशिएशन प्रोटोकॉल शिप। शिप
इज द मोस्ट वाइडली अडॉप्टेड सिग्नलिंग
प्रोटोकॉल इन द वर्ल्ड। जो शिप है शिप
सबसे ज्यादा ज्यादा वाइडली अडॉप्टेड
सिग्नलिंग प्रोटोकॉल्स हैं। प्रोटोकॉल्स
हैं। मॉडर्न वॉइस सिस्टम्स लाइक
एंटरप्राइज पीबीएक्स सिस्टम्स, सॉफ्ट
फोंस, आईपी फोंस, WhatsApp कॉल फ्लो,
Zoom, Microsoft रूम एटसेट्रा ऑलमोस्ट ऑल
ऑफ देम यूज शिफ्ट स्टाइल सिग्नलिंग
डायरेक्टली और इनडायरेक्टली। मतलब यह है
कि जितने भी मॉडर्न वाइब सिस्टम्स है जैसे
कि आपका एंटप्राइज के जो पीबी सिस्टम्स हो
गए आपके सॉफ्ट फस हो गए चाहे आपके IP फोन
हो गए WhatsApp कॉल फ्लो हो गया या zूम
मीटिंग्स हो गई आपकी या Microsoft टीम्स
हो गई सब ऑलमोस्ट क्या करते हैं आपके
डायरेक्टली या डायरेक्टली शिप के जो
स्टाइल
जो काम करने का जो स्टाइल है शिप का उसी
को ही क्या करते हैं फॉलो करते हैं हो
सकता है डायरेक्ट शिप को नहीं यूज़ करें बट
जो उसका जो तरीका है कैसे हैंडशक होगा।
कैसे मैसेजेस जाएंगे, किस टाइप के मेथड्स
होंगे, किस टाइप के हेडर्स होंगे, वह सारे
चीज़ उसी टाइप से वह फॉलो करते हैं। एंड
शिप वाज़ डेवलप्ड बाय द आईटीएफ इंटरनेट
इंजीनियरिंग टास्क फ़ोर्स। जो शिप है, शिप
को किसने डेवलप किया है? इंटरनेट
इंजीनियरिंग टास्क फोर्स ने उसको डेवलप
किया है और द सेम ऑर्गेनाइजेशन दैट
क्रिएटेड मेजर इंटरनेट स्टैंडर्ड्स लाइक
एचटीटीपी टीसीपीआईपी डीएनएस और एसएमटीपी
एटसेट्रा जो आईटीएफ है वो यह वही
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है जिसने क्या किया कि आपका
जो एचटीटीपी है आपके टीसीपीआईपी है आपका
डीएनएस है या एसएमटीपी जैसे जो भी इंटरनेट
के जो स्टैंडर्ड्स जो बनाया है यही वही
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है जिसने शिप को भी क्या
किया है डेवलप किया है अभी जो शिप है। शिप
का प्राइमरी एम क्या था? जो ट्रेडिशनल
डेस्क फोन थे या हम बोले जो पीएसटीए
पब्लिक स्विच टेलीफोन नेटवर्क थे उनकी
डिपेंडेंसी को रिप्लेस करना था। अब
क्योंकि जो पहले टेलीफोन नेटवर्क थे वो
हार्डवेयर बेस होते थे या हार्डवेयर
डिपेंडेंट होते थे। लेकिन shift ने क्या
किया? कॉलिंग को आईपी बेस बना दिया या
सॉफ्टवेयर ड्रिवन या डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड या
सस्ते बना दिया। यह हम बोल सकते हैं। दैट
इज आवर शिप है। नेक्स्ट हम बात करते हैं
H323 आईटीयूटी स्टैंडर्ड। तो H323 इज एन
ओल्डर सिग्नलिंग प्रोटोकॉल दैट वाज वेरी
पॉपुलर बिफोर शिप बिकम डोमिनेंट। अभी क्या
है कि जो H323 है यह एक ओल्डर सिग्नलिंग
प्रोटोकॉल्स है जो शिप के आने से पहले
काफी पॉपुलर था। इट वाज़ डेवलप्ड बाय
आईटीयूटी। इंटरनेशनल टेलीकम्युनिकेशन
यूनियन टेलीकम्युनिकेशंस।
इसको डेवलप किया था किसने? आईटीयूटी ने।
इंटरनेशनल टेलीकम्युनिकेशन यूनियन
टेलीकम्युनिकेशन से। अब किस पर्पस से इसको
डेवलप किया गया था? प्राइमरी इसको वीडियो
कॉन्फ्रेंसिंग के लिए डिजाइन किया गया था।
उसके बाद यह क्या है? वॉइस कॉल को भी
सपोर्ट करता था। यह काफी हैवी कॉम्प्लेक्स
और रिच्ड प्रोटोकॉल था। मतलब काफी
स्ट्रांग प्रोटोकॉल था। एंड उसके बाद
ट्रेडिशनल जो भी
जो टेलीकॉम वर्ल्ड थे उसमें भी काफी यूज़
होता था। और धीरे-धीरे अभी जब शिप से शिप
आ गया है उसके बाद इसको यूज़ करना कम कर
दिया लोगों ने। तो वी कैन से दैट कि यह
क्या है? एक ओल्ड स्कूल प्रोटोकॉल है जो
स्काइप के अर्ली वर्जनंस या जो ओल्ड
एंटरप्राइज सिस्टम्स थे उनमें यूज किया
जाता था। यह हम बोल सकते हैं वी कैन से
दैट। ओके? तो उसके बाद हम बात करते हैं
एससीसीपी। यह क्या था? स्किनी क्लाइंट
कंट्रोल प्रोटोकॉल सिस्को के द्वारा बनाया
गया। यह क्या है? एससीसीपी आल्सो नोन एज
स्किनी इज ए सिसको प्रोपराइटरी सिग्नल
प्रोटोकॉल। यह sिस्को का प्रोपराइटरी
सिग्नल प्रोटोकॉल है। इसका मतलब यह है कि
जो इट दिस मींस इट वाज यूज्ड ओनली इन
sisco आईपी फस और sisco कॉल मैनेजर
सिस्टम। इसको सिर्फ sिसको आईपी फोन और
सिसकल कॉल मैनेजर में ही देखने को मिलता
था। उसी में यूज़ किया जाता था। और इसको
स्किनी इसलिए बोला जाता है क्योंकि यह
लाइट वेट था और कम बैंडविड्थ लेता था। तो
आई होप कि ये तीनों चीज को क्लियर हो गए
होंगे। ओवरव्यू आपको समझ में आ गया होगा
कि आपका एचसीपी अह एचसीसीपी क्या होता है?
H3 H323 क्या होता है? और एसआईपी क्या
होता है? शिप के बारे में तो हम बिल्कुल
और भी डिटेल्स में पढ़ने वाले हैं क्योंकि
दिस इज आवर मेन प्रोटोकॉल जिसके बारे में
हमें डिटेल्स में रिसर्च करनी है।
क्लियर गाइस?
अरे बताओ यार।
चलिए अभी हम बात करने वाले हैं शिप के
बारे में डिटेल्स में बात करेंगे क्योंकि
दिस इज़ आवर मोस्टेंट प्रोटोकॉल। तो सेशन
इनिशिएशन प्रोटोकॉल शिप क्या है? SHप इज़ ए
टेक्स्ट बेस्ड सिग्नलिंग प्रोटोकॉल सिमिलर
टू HTTP। शिप क्या है? आपका एक टेक्स्ट
बेस प्रोटोकॉल है बिल्कुल किसकी तरह
एचटीटीपी की तरह और सबको पता है कि
एचटीटीपी क्या है? हाइपर टेक्स्ट ट्रांसफर
प्रोटोकॉल्स के उसके रिस्पांस होता था।
उसका हेडर्स होता था मतलब रिक्वेस्ट और
रिस्पांस जैसे उसके हेडर्स होते थे। उसी
प्रकार से यह भी है। मैसेजेस आर ह्यूमन
रीडेबल्स अनलेस इंक्रिप्टेड विद टीएलएस।
मतलब अगर आप शिप मैसेजेस को वx आर में ओपन
करके देखोगे तो क्या होगा? आपको प्लेन
टेक्स्ट में देखने को मिलेंगे। मतलब
ह्यूमन रीडेबल फॉर्म में देखने को
मिलेंगे। इंक्रिप्टेड नहीं देखने को
मिलेंगे। अनलेस जब तक उस उसके साथ टीएलएस
यूज़ नहीं किया गया है। यूज्ड फॉर कॉल
सेटअप, कंट्रोल एंड टियर डाउन इन वाइप
सिस्टम। इसका यूज़ किसके लिए किया जाता है?
आपकी जो कंट्रोल सेटअप जैसे मैं आपको बता
चुका हूं। उसके जो कंट्रोल सेटअप या आपके
सेटअप कॉल सेटअप के लिए या हम बोल सकते
हैं कॉल टर्मिनेशन के लिए यूज़ किया जाता
है। किसके अंदर? वॉइप सिस्टम के अंदर। डज
नॉट कैरी ऑडियो और वीडियो ओनली सिग्नलिंग
इंस्ट्रक्शन। यह क्या करता है? ना तो कोई
ऑडियो कैरी करता है ना कोई ऑडियो वीडियो
सिग्नल कैरी करता। ओनली सिग्नलिंग
इंस्ट्रक्शंस को ही फॉलो करता है। कौन सी
सेशन को सेटअप कर दिया एक्सेप्ट करवा
दिया। रिंग रिंग है उसको टर्मिनेट कर दिया
बाय ये सारे मैसेजेस हैंडल करता है। बाकी
नेक्स्ट कंपेयर करते हैं कि शिप वर्सेस
एचटीटीp। तो क्या होता है कि शिप का जो
मैसेज फॉर्मेट है वो काफी सिमिलर है http
के तरह। जैसे कि एचटीटीपी में क्या होता
है? गेट, पोस्ट, पुट, डिलीट मेथड होते
हैं। ठीक उसी प्रकार से शिप में भी
इनवाइट, रजिस्टर, बाय और कैंसिल मेथड्स
होते हैं। और http में भी है हेडर होते
हैं और शिप में भी हेडर्स आपको देखने को
मिलते हैं। और जब आप क्या करते हो? जब भी
आप क्या जो आपके जो शिप ट्रैफिक है उसको
जब भी आप एनालाइज़ करोगे तो आपको क्या है
कि शिप के अंदर मेथड्स देखने को मिलेंगे।
एग्जजेक्टली लाइक जैसे आपको एचटीटीपी के
अंदर मेथड्स देखने को मिलते हैं। गेट पुट
पोस्ट वैसे ही इसके अंदर भी आपको देखने को
मिलेंगे। रजिस्टर मेथड है या बाय मेथड है
या कैंसिल मेथड है या इनवाइट मेथड है। और
जैसे कि आपको एचटीटीपी में हैदर्स होते
हैं। जैसे होस्ट हैदर है हेडर होता है।
यूजर एजेंट हैडर हेडर होता है या कंटेंट
टाइप हेडर होता है। उसी प्रकार से शिप के
हेडर कौन से हैं? वाया फ्रॉम टू कॉल आईडी
कांटेक्ट
कमांड सीक्वेंस मैक्सिमम फॉरवर्ड्स कंटेंट
लेंथ कंटेंट टाइप ये सारे हेडर्स किसके
हैं आपके शिप के हैं जैसे कि उसमें भी
होते हैं आपके एचटीटीपी के अंदर ठीक वैसे
ही शिप के अंदर भी होते हैं। तो वी कैन से
दैट कि जो ये हेडर्स हैं जितने भी मैंने
आपको बताया वाया फ्रॉम टू कॉल कांटेक्ट ये
सारे के सारे क्या करते हैं? शिप कॉल फ्लो
को डिस्क्राइब करते हैं। मतलब इसी के बेस
पर जो क्लाइंट सर्वर कन्वर्जेशंस होता है,
वह इसी के बेस पर ही होता है। नाउ यह इसका
कंपैरिजन है। जैसे गेट है, इसमें इनवाइट
है। कॉल स्टार्ट करने के लिए इसमें पोस्ट
है, इसमें एकनॉलेजमेंट है। इसमें डिलीट
है, इसमें बाय है। इसमें ऑप्शन है। इसमें
भी ऑप्शंस है। इसमें मैसेज है। इसमें भी
मैसेजेस है। नेक्स्ट। उसके बाद रोल क्या
है? शिपका वॉइप में। रोल्स क्या है आपका?
शिपका वॉइस के अंदर। इट हैंडल्स कॉल
इनिशिएशन, रिंगिंग, एक्सेप्टेंस, रिजेक्शन
एंड टर्मिनेशन। यह सबको पता है। एंड डज
नॉट ट्रांसमिट मीडिया। मीडिया ट्रांसमिट
करने के लिए नहीं है। यह यही चीजें हैंडल
करता है। कॉल को इनिशिएट करना, रिंग करना,
एक्सेप्ट करना, रिजेक्ट करना, टर्मिनेट
करना। उसके बाद ऑडियो और वीडियो क्या करता
है? यह हैंडल नहीं करता। लेकिन यह किसके
द्वारा हैंडल की जाती है? आरटीपी के
द्वारा। शिप वर्क विद एसडीपी फॉर मीडिया
नेगोशिएशन। मैं आपको एक चीज बताता हूं कि
शिप अकेला काम नहीं करता। शिप क्या करता
है? कॉल सेटअप के लिए शिप यूज़ होता है।
लेकिन मीडिया नेगोशिएशन के लिए एक और
प्रोटोकॉल है जिसका यूज़ किया जाता है वो
एसडीपी है। एसडीपी क्या करता है? एसडीपी
में डिफाइन होता है कि कौन से कोडक का यूज़
होगा? कौन से पोर्ट पे आरटीपी का यूज़
होगा? या आरटीपी के लिए कौन सा पोर्ट
होगा? वॉइस होगा या वीडियो कॉल होगा। उसका
पैकेट का फॉर्मेट क्या होगा? या और भी
अदर्स जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए मीडिया
आरटीपी के साथ कम के थ्रू कम्युनिकेशन के
लिए वो सारे किसके अंदर होते हैं? आपके
एसडीपी के अंदर होते हैं। तो वी कैन से
दैट जो शिप है शिप कॉल कंट्रोल करता है।
एसडीपी आपका मेड मीडिया नेगोशिएशन करता है
और जो आपका आरटीपी है वो वॉइस और वीडियो
पैकेट के साथ डील करता है। तो ये तीनों
तीनों क्या करते हैं? एक साथ काम करते
हैं। नाउ कम्स टू आवर ट्रांसपोर्ट
प्रोटोकॉल सपोर्टेड बाय शिप। SHप के
द्वारा कौन-कौन से ट्रांसपोर्ट प्रोटोकॉल
सपोर्ट किए जाते हैं? शिप सपोर्ट्स
मल्टीपल ट्रांसपोर्ट यूडीपी, टीसीटीp,
एचटीटीp, वेब सॉकेट या एचटीटीपी। अभी बहुत
सारे प्रोटोकॉल्स क्या होते हैं कि एक ही
ट्रांसपोर्ट प्रोटोकॉल पे चलते हैं। या तो
कह डीएनएस ओवर यूडीपी या एचडीटीपी ओवर
टीसीपी काम करते हैं। बट जो शिप है काफी
फ्लैक्सिबल है। शिप क्या है? मल्टीपल
ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल सपोर्ट करता है। जैसे
आपका यूडीपी हो गया, टीसीपी हो गया और
मोस्ट कॉमन कौन सा आपका? यूडीपी है,
एचटीटीपी हो गया या फिर आपके वेब सॉकेट्स
इनके थ्रू भी यह काम करता है। नेक्स्ट
सिक्योरिटी कंसीडरेशन की बात करें शिप
क्या होता है? बाय डिफॉल्ट प्लेन टेक्स्ट
होता है और इसका पोर्ट नंबर क्या होता है?
5060 होता है जो काफी इजी होता है
इंटरसेप्ट करना। वहीं पर अगर शिप क्या है
कि टीएलएस के साथ यूज़ किया जा रहा है।
मतलब पोर्ट नंबर 5061 तो इसका मतलब क्या
है? यहां पर इंक्रिप्टेड डाटा आपको देखने
को मिलेगा जिसको हम बोलते हैं शिप्स।
सिक्योर शिप से और इसका काम क्या होता है?
यह क्या इंश्योर करता है कि जो भी शिप
मैसेज है वह इंक्रिप्ट हो जाए। जो कॉलर
आईडी जो कॉलर आईडी की जो स्पुफिंग जैसी
चीजें हैं उसको कम किया जा सके। जो शिप
क्रेडेंशियल स्निफ किए जा सकते हैं। जो
शिप्स के जो क्रेडेंशियल है उसको स्निफ
करने से प्रिवेंट किया जा सके। एमआईटीएम
अटैक को रिड्यूस किया जा सके। ये सारी
चीजों के लिए इसका यूज़ किया जाता है। अगर
आप टीएलएस का यूज़ नहीं करोगे तो फिर क्या
हो जाता है? किसी भी अटैकर के लिए ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स करना इजी हो जाता है, इंटरसेप्शन
करना इजी हो जाता है, रिप्ले अटैक करना
इजी हो जाता है या हाईजैक करना भी काफी ही
इजी हो जाता है। तो दैट इज कॉल्ड आवर शिप।
तो आई थिंक कि ये चीज आपको क्लियर हो गई
होगी। यहां तक शिप प्रोटोकॉल समझ में आ
गया। अभी हम थोड़ा सा और अच्छे
प्रैक्टिकल्स पे जाने वाले हैं या थोड़ा
सा मजेदार चीज पे जाने वाले हैं। समझ में
आया?
जल्दी से बताओ। शिप प्रोटोकॉल के बारे में
किसी को कोई डाउट है? शिप सबको समझ में आ
गया?
बिल्कुल सबको
बिल्कुल समझ में आ गया सबको। अच्छी बात
है। फिर नहीं समझ में आया। क्या हुआ?
एनी डाउट? 143
क्या समझ में नहीं आया। बस बताओ जल्दी से।
मैं आपकी चैट देख रहा हूं। उसके बाद हम
इसके बाद बिल्कुल समझ में आ जाए क्या डाउट
है बताओ
बताओ बताओ जिसको डाउट है एक बार पूछ लो
अच्छा रहेगा मन में नहीं रखना चाहिए
मुझे पता है कि यह चीजें आपके लिए बहुत नई
है। आपको कोई आईडिया भी नहीं है।
ओके समझ में आ गया तो अच्छी बात है। तो
नाउ
अभी हम देखते हैं शिप कॉल फ्लो क्या होता
है कि एक डायग्राम दी डायग्राम रिप्रेजेंट
ए कंप्लीट शिप कॉल फ्लो सेटअप मीडिया
एक्सचेंज एंड कॉल टर्मिनेशन। मैं एक
डायग्राम शो करूंगा मतलब वन बाय स्टेप बाय
स्टेप कि जो शिप का जो कॉल फ्लो है जो आप
मैं आपको बताना शिप का जो हैंडशेक कैसे
होता है उस हैंडशक को मैं काफी स्टेप बाय
स्टेप आपको रिप्रेजेंट करने वाला हूं
किसके बीच में दो एंड पॉइंट्स के बीच में
कॉलर ए है जिसको हम कॉलर कॉलर बोलेंगे और
कॉलर बी एक कोली जिसको मैं कॉल करने वाला
हूं उसके बीच में हम रीडक्स सर्वर का भी
यूज़ करने वाले हैं। एक प्रॉक्सी सर्वर
है। मतलब यह सेटअप है कि कॉलर ए कॉलर बी
को कॉल करने वाला है। तो वह कैसे हैंडशक
होगा? बीच में एक रीडायरेक्ट सर्वर है, एक
प्रॉक्सी सर्वर है। आपको समझ में आ जाएगा।
शिप सिग्नलिंग कंट्रोल द जो शिप सिग्नलिंग
कंट्रोल द कॉल सेटअप एंड टियर डाउन व्हाइल
द एक्चुअल वॉइस फ्लो थ्रू आरटीपी। जैसा
मैंने आपको बताया कि जो सिग्नलिंग चैनल है
वह कॉल सेटअप और टियर डाउन के लिए
रिस्पांसिबल होता है। व पर जो आपका
एक्चुअल फ्लो है जो वॉइस फ्लो किसके थ्रू
जाएगा? आरटीपी के थ्रू। तो लेट गाइस आर यू
रेडी?
आर यू राइट गाइस?
पहले चीजें समझो जगत गुरु जी
पूरा जब कांसेप्ट हो जाए तब यह डाउट लेके
आना। तो देखने के लिए रेडी हो?
चलिए तो फॉर एग्जांपल यह कॉलर ए है। यह
कॉलर बी है। बीच में एक प्रॉक्सी सर्वर
है। यह रीडायरेक्ट सर्वर। अब डिपेंड्स ऐसा
ही नहीं हो सकता है कि दो प्रोक्सी हो,
तीन प्रॉक्सी हो या रीडायरेक्ट सर्वर नहीं
हो। डिपेंड्स ऑन द सेटअप। यह सेटअप के ऊपर
डिपेंड करता है। फॉर एग्जांपल, कॉलर ए
इनिशिएट ए कॉल एंड सेंड एन इनवाइट
रिक्वेस्ट। कॉलर ए क्या करता है कि कॉल
इनिशिएट करता है और क्या करता है? इनवाइट
रिक्वेस्ट भेजता है। जैसे मैंने आपको
बताया मेथड था ना एचटीटी में गेट पोस्ट
वैसे इनवाइट रिक्वेस्ट भेजता है कि आई
वांट टू कॉलर कॉल कॉलर बी कि वो रीडक्स
सर्वर को क्या बोलता है कि मुझे कॉलर बी
को कॉल करनी है। बिकॉज़ सिंस कॉलर ए डज़ नॉट
नो कॉलर बी एग्जैक्ट लोकेशन। क्योंकि जो
कॉलर बी है उसको उसकी एग्जैक्ट लोकेशन
नहीं पता। शी सेंड द रिक्वेस्ट टू अ
रीडायरेक्ट सर्वर। वो क्या करता है जो
रीडायरेक्ट सर्वर है उसको रिक्वेस्ट भेज
देता है कि मुझे क्या करना है कॉलर बी को
कॉल करनी है तो कैसे करूं क्योंकि इसको
नहीं पता एग्जैक्ट लोकेशन क्या है कि कैसे
जाना है इस रास्ते तक ये रीडायरेक्ट सर्वर
के पास इसने इनवाइट रिक्वेस्ट भेज दी उसके
बाद क्या स्टेप टू में जो रीडायरेक्ट
सर्वर था उसने रिप्लाई किया 302
मूव टेंपरेरी व्हिच बेसिकली मीन कॉलर बी
इज नॉट देयर हियर कॉलर बी यहां पर नहीं है
बट यू शुड कांटेक्ट दिस प्रॉक्स इंस्टेड
कि आप एक काम कीजिए इस प्रोक्सी पर
कांटेक्ट करो। मतलब इसने एड्रेस दिया कि
कॉलर भी मेरे पास नहीं है बट आपको इससे
पता चल जाएगा। रिीडायरेक्ट कर दिया इसलिए
302 परमानेंटली आपको देखने को मिला।
नेक्स्ट स्टेप क्या किया? ओके। कोलारिया
ने क्या किया? एकनॉलेजमेंट भेजा दैट
रीडायरेक्ट रिस्पांस बाय सेंडिंग एन एसीके
मैसेज। दिस कंप्लीट द ट्रांजिशन विद
रीडायरेक्ट सर्वर। इसने क्या किया कि यहां
पर एकनॉलेजमेंट मैसेज भेज दिया रीडक सर्वर
को और अपनी जो
बातचीत थी रीडायरेक्ट सर्वर के साथ बंद कर
दी मतलब इसकी जो
बातचीत हुई थी रीडायरेक्ट सर्वर के साथ जो
ट्रांजैक्शन हुई थी उसको क्या कर दिया
क्लोज कर दिया ओके बोला इनवाइट मैसेज भेज
दिया इसने बोला नहीं आप इस पे एक काम करो
प्रॉक्सी सर्वर के पास जाओ और यहां पे यह
मैसेज भेजो हो सकता है आपको यहां देख पता
मिल जाए और इसने ओके आपको ओके किया थम्स
अप किया चलो यहां पे इसका कंप्लीट हो गया
नेक्स्ट स्टेप फोर में क्या हो गया? स्टेप
फोर में क्या किया? जो यूजर ए था या जो
कॉलर ए जिसको हम बोल सकते हैं उसने क्या
किया? मैसेज भेजा। इनवाइट मैसेज भेजा।
किसको? प्रॉक्सी सर्वर को। उन्होंने किसको
भेजा? प्रॉक्सी सर्वर को। इनवाइट मैसेज
भेजा। जहां पर मैं यूजर ए बोल रहा हूं या
कॉलर ए बोल रहा हूं तो वह समझ जाना। तो
यूजर ए नाउ सेंड ए इनवाइट इनवाइट टू
प्रॉक्सी सर्वर। आई वाज़ रिीडायरेक्टेड। सो
नाउ आई एम सेंडिंग सेंडिंग द कॉल टू यू।
प्लीज कांटेक्ट मी टू यूजर बी। मैं इसने
बोला कि मैं आपको इनवाइट मैसेज भेज रहा
हूं और मेरे को फॉरवर्ड किया गया आपके पास
रिडक्स सर्वर के थ्रू और मुझे किसके पास
कॉल करना है कॉलर बी के पास कॉल करना है
तो मैं कैसे करूं इसने इसके पास ये
रिक्वेस्ट भेजी प्रॉक्सी सर्वर के पास जब
प्रॉक्सी सर्वर के पास रिक्वेस्ट भेजी तो
क्या हुआ उसके बाद इसने क्या किया इसने इस
रिक्वेस्ट को फॉरवर्ड किया प्रॉक्सी सर्वर
ने किसके पास फॉरवर्ड किया कॉलर बी के पास
इनवाइट मैसेज ओके दी इस दिस इनवाइट इज इज़
फॉरवर्ड टू द टू द प्रोक्सी सिंस द
प्रोक्सी नोज़ कॉलर बीज़ लोकेशन। क्योंकि
कॉलर बी के जो लोकेशनेशंस है वो किसके पास
थी? प्रोक्सी के पास थी कि कॉलर बी की
लोकेशन क्या है? कैसे उसको कांटेक्ट करना
है? उसने क्या किया? यह जो इनवाइट मैसेज
था किसको फॉरवर्ड कर दिया? आपके कॉलर बी
को। द प्रोक्सी फॉरवर्ड द इनवाइट टू कॉलर
बी। यहां तक सबको क्लियर हो गया? यहां तक
सबको क्लियर है? क्योंकि यह चीज अगर यहां
भी क्लियर नहीं हो तो आगे कंफ्यूज हो
जाएंगी। यहां तक क्लियर है सबको? थ्री वे
हैंड चेक नहीं है यह।
एकदम यहां तक क्लियर है। स्टेप फाइव तक
क्लियर है कि इनवाइट मैसेज पहुंच गया कॉलर
बी के पास।
ओके। उसके बाद क्या हुआ?
नेक्स्ट। उसके बाद क्या किया कि जो
प्रॉक्सी सर्वर था प्रॉक्सी सर्वर ने
सिक्स स्टेप में 100 ट्राइंग मैसेज किसके
पास भेजा? कॉलर ए के पास अपॉन रिसीविंग द
इनवाइट द प्रोक्सी इमीडिएटली रिटर्न 100
ट्राइंग मतलब जैसे ही इसने क्या किया
इनवाइट मैसेज मिला था फॉर के बाद और इसने
उसको फॉरवर्ड किया बी के पास तो सेम टाइम
इसने क्या किया 100 ट्राइंग मैसेज भेजा
इसका मतलब क्या था कि मुझे आपकी रिक्वेस्ट
मिल गई है लेकिन मैं इसको प्रोसेस कर रहा
हूं मैं पता लगा रहा हूं इसका मतलब था यह
ट्राइंग उसके बाद क्या हुआ स्टेप सिक्स
में कि कॉलर बी के फोन रिंग होना क्योंकि
देखो कॉलर बी के पास चला गया और उसके जो
फोन था उसमें घंटी आना स्टार्ट हो गई।
रिंग बजना स्टार्ट हो गई। जैसा आप देख पा
रहे हो कि कॉलर बीज फोन स्टार्ट रिंगिंग
कॉलर बी डिवाइस नोटिफाई द प्रॉक्सी 1880
रिंगिंग। उसने क्या किया कि प्रॉक्सी
सर्वर को फिर एक मैसेज भेजा 1880 रिंगिंग
मैसेज भेजा। किसको? प्रॉक्सी सर्वर। इसका
मतलब क्या है कि कॉलर बी का जो फोन है वह
रिंग कर रहा है। रिंगिंग मैसेज किसको
भेजा? किसने? प्रॉक्सी सर्वर को। उसके बाद
प्रॉक्सी सर्वर ने क्या किया? द प्रोक्सी
फॉरवर्ड 1880 रिंगिंग बै बैक टू कॉलर ए
एंड कोजिंग हर डिवाइस टू प्ले द रिंग टोन
और जब आपको देखा आपने देखा होगा कि जो
रिंगिंग टोन आपको सुनने को मिलती है जो भी
रिंग टोन आपको सुनती है वो इसकी वजह से
सुनती है क्योंकि सेवन के बाद ए स्टेप में
क्या किया इदर रिंग बजना स्टार्ट होगी सेम
टाइम इसने यह मैसेज किसको फॉरवर्ड किया
प्रोक्सी सर्वर ने किसको आपके कॉलर ए को
और कॉलर ए को जैसे मैसेज फॉरवर्ड किया तो
आपको सुनाई देता है एक साइड में कि ओके
रिंग बज रही है मतलब मेरी कॉल जा रही है
सामने वाली पार्टी के पास यहां तक क्लियर
होगा शायद उसके बाद क्या हुआ देन कॉलर बी
ने कॉल को आंसर किया जैसे ही कॉलर बी ने
कॉल को आंसर किया क्या होगा कॉलर बी आंसर
द कॉल तो कॉलर बी के फोन से एक मैसेज आया
200 ओके कि कॉलर बी ने क्या किया उसको फोन
को उठा लिया आंसर करने के लिए कि पिकअप कर
लिया फोन पिकअप करते क्या 200 ओके मैसेज
गया किसके पास प्रॉक्सी के पास कि कॉल
कॉलर बी एक्सेप्टेड द कॉल हियर कॉलर बीज
मीडिया डिटेल्स और अब जब फोन तो एक्सेप्ट
कर लिया एक्सेप्ट करने के बाद आपको क्या
बताना है एसडीपी क्योंकि मीडिया जो आरटीपी
जो सर्वर है उसके थ्रू कम्युनिकेट कैसे
होगा कौन-कौन सी और किस टाइप की ऑडियो
होगी किस टाइप का जो भी सब कुछ था वो क्या
है कि आपके आरटीपी सर्वर की डिटेल्स इसके
साथ चली गई और इसने क्या किया वो 200 ओके
मैसेज किसको भेजा कॉलर ए के पास को कि हां
सामने वाली पार्टी ने आपका फोन उठा लिया
नाउ बोथ कॉलर ए एंड कॉलर बी हैज एक्सचेंज
ईच अदर जो उसने क्या किया एक दूसरे के
आईपी एड्रेससेस को एक्सचेंज कर लिया
आरटीपी पोर्ट को एक्सचेंज कर लिया कोड
कैपेबिलिटीज सारी चीज एसडीपी के थ्रू क्या
कर लिया उसने एक्सचेंज कर ली मतलब शेयर हो
गई 200 हो गई मतलब पीियर टू पीियर कनेक्शन
बन गया अभी देन उसके बाद क्या हुआ
एकनॉलेजमेंट मैसेज आया किसकी तरफ से ओके
कॉलर ए की तरफ से एकनॉलेजमेंट कंफर्म कॉलर
ए कंफर्म रिसीप्ट ऑफ द 200 ओके मैसेज बाय
सेंडिंग एंड एकनॉलेजमेंट तो प्रोक्सी उसने
क्या किया ओके मुझे जो आपने मैसेज भेजा
मिल गया है उसका एकनॉलेजमेंट मैसेज किसको
भेजा प्रोक्सी सर्वर को प्रोक्सी ने क्या
किया कोलरबी को एकनॉलेजमेंट मैसेज भेज
दिया और इस मोमेंट तक क्या था आपका शिप
हैंडशक कंप्लीट हो गया यहां तक हो गया
आपका शिप हैंडशक कंप्लीट यहां तक समझ में
आ गया शिप हैंडशक तक सबको
नहीं होगा क्योंकि उसने उसके अंदर जो
एड्रेस है वह प्रोक्स सर्वर का है।
डायरेक्ट कॉलर बी का एड्रेस नहीं है। अमन
इसीलिए
तो यहां तक सबको समझ में आ गया? यहां तक
किसी को कोई डाउट है? क्योंकि यह है आपका
हैंडशक जो आप ज्यादातर जीसी के बेस पर आप
क्या करते हो? कैप्चर करने वाले हो,
डिक्रिप्शन करने वाले हो। इसके अंदर सारी
कहानी छुपी हुई है क्योंकि जब हम आगे आगे
बढ़ेंगे इन पैकेट्स को हम स्टेप बाय स्टेप
देखने वाले भी हैं वायरस आर्क में
प्रैक्टिकली डोंट वरी
सबको क्लियर क्लियर हो गया किसी को डाउट
है इसमें ध्यान से मैं एक काम कर रहा हूं
अभी आपके सामने अगले 30 सेकंड के लिए एक
मिनट के लिए आपके स्क्रीन पर छोड़ देता
हूं प्लीज एक बार खुद से स्टेप वन स्टेप
टू स्टेप थ्री स्टेप फोर फाइव सिक्स 7 8 9
10 11 12 को एक काम कर लो देख लो पढ़ लो
किसका मतलब क्या मैंने बताया था एक बार
रिवाइज कर लो अगर कोई डाउट है तो मुझसे
पूछ लो क्योंकि इट इज वेरी वेरीेंट
प्रैक्टिकल्स तो प्रैक्टिकल तो अभी साथ के
साथ करवाऊंगा तो आज नहीं होगा तो कल हो
जाएगा नेक्स्ट क्लास में हो जाएगा डोंट
वरी प्रैक्टिकल्स आपको हमेशा होगा
प्रैक्टिकल्स मैं आपको दिखाऊंगा डोंट वरी
प्रैक्टिकल मैं मेरे पास है इसके एमआईटीएम
ट्रैफिक है सॉरी इसके जो
वेब ट्रैफिक के पिक फाइल्स हैं उनसे ही
दिखाऊंगा मैं।
एक छोटा सा डेमोंस्ट्रेशन तो मैं आपको
दिखा दूंगा बट उसको पूरी तरह स्टेप बाय
स्टेप एनालाइज करना। हो सकता है कि आज की
क्लास में ना हो लेकिन नेक्स्ट में पक्का
हो जाएगा
क्योंकि पहले ये चीज समझो कि ये चीजें हैं
क्या? क्योंकि जो चीज आप वसार में देखोगे
तो फिर आप कंफ्यूज नहीं होगे।
तो 1 मिनट का समय है। एक बार देख लीजिए,
एनालाइज कर लीजिए और जब आप लोग एनालाइज कर
लो और समझ में आ जाए तो एक बार बोल देना
सर गो
टू नेक्स्ट स्टेप।
मैं आपका वेट कर रहा हूं।
मजा आए तो चैट में बता देना।
सब लोग जल्दी बताओ।
ओके बाकी लोग बाकी लोग नहीं बताओगे या
देखते ही नहीं बताओ या बाकी लोगों को समझ
में ही नहीं आता।
चलो फिर नेक्स्ट स्टेप पे चलते हैं। अगर
आप लोग नहीं बताना चाहते तो अच्छी बात है।
नेक्स्ट उसके बाद क्या हो गया? हैंड चेक
कंप्लीट हो गया। आपका जो एसडीपी ने सारी
डिटेल्स भेज दी। उसके बाद क्या होगा? आपका
मीडिया आरटीपी एक्टिवेट हो गया। नाउ
आरटीपी मीडिया वॉइस पैकेट बीइंग्स टू फॉलो
फ्लो डायरेक्टली बिटवीन कॉलर ए एंड कॉलर
बी जो कॉलर ए और कॉलर ए बी के बीच में
वॉइस कम्युनिकेशन स्टार्ट हो जाएगा चाहे
ऑडियो हो चाहे वीडियो हो वो कम्युनिकेशन
स्टार्ट हो गया जब अब जब ये कम्युनिकेशन
जितनी भी देर चलेगा वो इस पीियर टू पीियर
कम्युनिकेशन चलेगा बिल्कुल यह पीियर टू
पीियर कम्युनिकेशन होगा क्योंकि इतने सारे
स्टेप परफॉर्म होने के बाद आपका क्या हुआ
है यह कम्युनिकेशन इस्टैब्लिश हुआ जो आपको
पता भी नहीं चलता इतना फास्ट होता और यह
आपका मीडिया सर्वर के थ्रू कम्युनिकेशन
स्टार्ट हो गया। जब एक बार क्या हुआ किसी
भी कॉल या तो कॉलर ए ने या कॉलर बी ने
किसी ने भी टर्मिनेट किया। फॉर एग्जांपल
कॉलर बी ने इसको टर्मिनेट कर दिया। ओके
बेली मेरी बात खत्म हो गई। मैं कॉल को
फिनिश करना चाहता हूं। तो क्या होगा? फिर
बाय मैसेज गया। बाय मैसेज किसकी तरफ से
आएगा? कॉलर बी की तरफ से। उसने भेजा
किसको? मीडिया सर् अ प्रॉक्सी सर्वर को।
प्रॉक्सी सर्वर ने किसको भेजा? कॉलर ए को।
बाय बो कनेक्शन टर्मिनेट उसने फोन रख दिया
है। ओके उसके बाद 200 ओके मैसेज आता है।
किसकी तरफ से? कॉलर ए की तरफ से। और उसको
किसको फॉरवर्ड कर दिया? वो कॉलर बी को 200
ओके मैसेज भेज दिया। इस तरीके से आपका
क्या हो गया? कनेक्शन क्लोज हो गया।
मीडिया सर्वर का भी कनेक्शन क्लोज हो गया।
और आपकी कॉल कट हो गई। आपका कने जो कॉल
टर्म टर्मिनेट हो गया। तो आई होप कि काफी
इजी था। तो इस तरीके से क्या होता है आपका
कॉल टर्मिनेट होता है जो भी मैं आपको बता
रहा हूं इनवाइट है एसी के है यह एज वन जो
है फिक्स है यह मैसेज आपको देखने को
मिलेंगे वxआर के अंदर भी ओके बाय है 200
ओके है सारी चीजें
नेक्स्ट बिफोर एनी कॉल फ्लो कैन हैपन दिस
दिस शिप डिवाइस मस्ट रजिस्टर अभी एक और
चीज है कि यह तो मैंने आपको दिखाया कि कॉल
फ्लो कैसे होता है लेकिन कॉल फ्लो लॉ से
भी एक से भी पहले एक इंपॉर्टेंट चीज होती
है जो आपको समझनी जरूरी है क्योंकि यह तो
बीच का स्टेप है। उससे पहले भी एक काम
होता है। वह काम क्या होता है? मैं आपको
दिखाने वाला हूं। क्या होता है?
रजिस्ट्रेशन। वह काम क्या होता है?
रजिस्ट्रेशन। रजिस्ट्रेशन में क्या होता
है? अगर आप रजिस्ट्रेशन नहीं करोगे तो
कॉलर ए कैन नॉट मेक ए कॉल। कॉलर बी कैन
नॉट रिसीव ए कॉल। कि अगर आपने रजिस्ट्रेशन
नहीं किया आपके शिप सर्वर के साथ जो आपका
जो रीडक्स जो आपका प्रॉक्सी सर्वर था ना
उसके साथ आपने अगर वह कॉल मेक कॉल वो नहीं
किया मतलब कि रजिस्ट्रेशन नहीं किया तो
क्या होगा कॉलर ए कॉल नहीं कर सकता कॉलर
बी कॉल रिसीव नहीं कर सकता द प्रॉक्सी डज़
नॉट नो वेयर कॉलर ए एंड कॉलर बी आर
लोकेटेड प्रॉक्सी को पता ही नहीं कि कॉलर
ए कहां पर है कॉलर बी कहां पर है द सर्वर
हैज़ नो कांटेक्ट बाइंडिंग सर्वर के पास
पास कोई भी कांटेक्ट बाइंडिंग नहीं है कि
मुझे किस पोर्ट पर या किस आईपी के साथ वह
कॉल इनिशिएट करनी है। क्योंकि कोई आईडिया
ही नहीं है क्योंकि एक दूसरे टेलीफोन ने
रजिस्टर किया ही नहीं है। एंड इनवाइट विल
फेल विद 44 नॉट फाउंड या 480 टेंपरेरी अन
अवेलेबल। उसके बाद क्या होगा कि आपको यह
एरर दे मैसेज मिलेगी कि 404 या 480 यह
सर्विस अन अवेलेबल है। मतलब अवेलेबल नहीं
है। तो यह था। तो यह इस तरीके से होता है।
उससे पहले क्या होता है? रजिस्ट्रेशन कैसे
होता है? कॉलर ए क्या है? उसको हम बोल
सकते हैं यूजर एजेंट क्लाइंट। मतलब हो
सकता है आपके पास अभी WhatsApp है तो
WhatsApp के थ्रू आप जब वॉइस कॉल करते हो
वो भी आपके पास यूजर एजेंट है या आप किसी
एंटरप्राइज एनवायरमेंट में आप वीडियो फोन
यूज़ करते हो या वॉइस कॉल के लिए फोन यूज़
करते हो या सॉफ्ट फोन यूज़ करते हो या
हार्ड फोन यूज़ करते हो। वह सब क्या है?
आपके यूजर एजेंट हैं। तो क्या होता है?
यूजर एडन सबसे पहले रजिस्टर करता है अपने
आप को रजिस्टर करते सबसे पहले क्या करता
है वो रजिस्टर मैसेज भेजता है और सेम टाइम
उसके पास जो यूजर एजेंट सर्वर होगा जो
आपका शिप सर्वर है या पीबीएक्स सर्वरर्स
है जो भी है वो क्या करता है आपको 401 अन
ऑथराइज्ड भेज देगा अब यह रजिस्टर मैसेज
भेजा अन ऑथराइज्ड मैसेज आया उसके बाद फिर
से जो कॉलर ए है और रजिस्टर मैसेज भेजेगा
उसके बाद कुछ यहां पर उसके क्रेडेंशियल्स
मैच होंगे उसके बाद 200 ओके मिलेगा तो यह
चीज हो कैसे रही है? यह चीज हम नेक्स्ट
क्लास में पूरी डिटेल्स में देखेंगे।
पैकेट बाय पैकेट मैं आपको काफी डिटेल्स
में बताऊंगा कि ओके यहां पर जब फर्स्ट
टाइम रजिस्टर भेजा गया 401 क्यों भेजा
उसके बाद सेकंड टाइम रजिस्टर मैसेज भेजा
गया फिर 200 ओके क्यों आया और तभी जाके
आपकी जो कंप्लीट जो प्रोसेस है
रजिस्ट्रेशन की वो कंप्लीट हो जाती है। तो
प्रैक्टिकली मैं आपको बताऊंगा यह चीज़। तो
ये चीज आपको समझ में आ गई होगी कि जो शिप
कॉल फ्लो आपने जो फ्लो देखा था यह वाला
इससे पहले यह होता है कौन सा रजिस्ट्रेशन
प्रोसेस होता है इससे पहले क्या होता है
आपका रजिस्ट्रेशन प्रोसेस होता है उसके
बाद ही आपका शिप फ्लो स्टार्ट होता है
इनवाइट मैसेज है इनवाइट मैसेज के बाद आपका
कनेक्शन एस्टैब्लिश होना मतलब जो शिप का
फुल हैंड सेक तभी होता है सबसे पहला स्टेप
क्या है दोनों एंड से चाहे आपका कॉलर ए है
कॉलर बी है दोनों एंड से जब तक यह नहीं
होगा तब तक के लिए क्या होगा। आप
कम्युनिकेट नहीं कर पाओगे क्योंकि आपका जो
सर्वर है उसको पता ही नहीं है कि मुझे
किसको कॉल फॉरवर्ड करनी है। किसके पास
कम्युनिकेट करना है।
नेक्स्ट आफ्टर आफ्टर द 200 ओके जब आपका जो
मैसेज आ जाएगा 200 ओके तो डिवाइस इज
रजिस्टर्ड प्रॉक्सी सर्वर नोट्स योर करंट
आईपी एंड पोर्ट यू कैन प्लेस कॉल यू कैन
रिसीव कॉल योर लोकेशन इज़ सेव्ड इन द
लोकेशन डेटाबेस। मतलब क्या है कि उसके बाद
सर्वर को पता है कि कहां पर आपको कॉल करनी
है। कैसे आपको कॉल रिसीव होगी और आपका
डेटाबेस उसके पास स्टोर रहता है। किस आईपी
पर कौन से पोर्ट पर यह सारी चीजें उसके
पास रहती है। किसके पास? शिप सर्वर के पास
जो प्रोक्सी सर्वर है उसके पास जो हम
रजिस्टर करते हैं उसके बाद ही वह आपका जो
इनवाइट वाला मैसेज है जो कहानी स्टार्ट
हुई तभी स्टार्ट हो पाती है क्योंकि उसको
पता है कि मुझे इस कांटेक्ट नंबर के लिए
कैसे कॉल करनी है ओनली आफ्टर दिस
रजिस्ट्रेशन दी कॉल फ्लो ग्राफ बिगेन जो
कॉल फ्लो ग्राफ है वह स्टार्ट होता है ओके
गाइज़ तो यह था आपका
आज की क्लास के लिए कांसेप्ट और एक और चीज
मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं फॉर एग्जांपल्स
इसका प्रैक्ट प्रैक्टिकली एक चीज है मेरे
पास। यह रहा
शिप आरटीपी एंड नॉर्मल कॉल फ्लो टू
पार्टीज। मैं इसको क्या एक काम करता हूं?
किसके साथ ओपन करता हूं? वसार के ओपन कर
वसार के साथ ओपन करता हूं। तो आपको दिखा
देता हूं एक बार। इसको ओपन कर देते हैं।
यह आपने देख लिया होगा। यह रहे देखो। एंड
इस तरीके से है। यह रहे मैसेज आपके शिप।
उसके बाद मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं कि
टेलीफ़ोनी गो टू योर शिप फ्लो। देन उसके
बाद यह सारे आपके शिप मैसेजेस हैं।
कंट्रोल ऑल सेलेक्ट किया। उसके बाद आपको
जाना है किसके? फ्लो सीक्वेंस। और जैसे
फ्लो सीक्वेंस पे जाओगे देखो ध्यान से।
दिस इज योर कंप्लीट फ्लो सीक्वेंस।
कॉलर वन कॉलर टू बीच में आपका प्रॉक्सी
सर्वर। इसमें क्या है? रीडायरेक्ट वाला
सीन नहीं दिखाया मैंने। यहां पर क्या हो
रहा है आपका? रजिस्ट्रेशन हो रहा है इस
साइड यहां पर क्लाइंट साइड भी आपका
रजिस्ट्रेशन हो रहा है। उसके बाद देखो
इनवाइट मैसेज है। उसके बाद 401 है या
एकनॉलेजमेंट है। यह सारे इनवाइट फिर से
भेजा गया। 100 ट्राइंग 180 रिंग उसके बाद
यह देखो 100 ट्राइंग 180 रिंग
180 रिंग ये सारी चीजें देखो। ध्यान से
पूरा ये डिटेल्स में है। देखो पूरा
डिटेल्स में देखो क्या-क्या चीज हो रही है
यहां पर? किस पॉइंट पर क्या चीज हो रही
है। ध्यान से देखो बिल्कुल ये चीजें मैंने
कुछ भी नहीं आपको नहीं बताया। देखो यह
रजिस्ट्रेशन प्रोसेस यह आपका शिफ्ट फ्लो
है। देखो यह देखो यह देखो बिल्कुल अन
ऑथराइज्ड भी है। रजिस्टर ये बहुत बहुत
सारी चीजें हैं इसमें जो अभी आप देखने से
नहीं समझ पाओगे। बट इट इज वेरी डीप। देख
पा रहे हो प्रैक्टिकल में भी कैसे दिख रहा
है आपको?
अगर मैं आपको यह फ्लो नहीं समझाता जो
मैंने आपको स्लाइड में समझाया तो आप यह
कभी नहीं समझ पाते।
सबको समझ में आ गया जो भी कुछ मैंने आपको
बताया क्योंकि मैं आपको ना तो ज्यादा
पढ़ाऊंगा ना कम पढ़ाऊंगा इतना पढ़ाऊंगा कि
आपको ना तो वह एक्स्ट्रा होगा ना ओवर होगा
और ना ज्यादा आपको प्रेशराइज करेगा चीजों
को समझने के लिए बिल्कुल स्टेप बाय स्टेप
टॉपिक बाय टॉपिक जाएंगे किसी दिन अगर
टॉपिक छोटा भी पढ़ाना पड़ जाए तो कोई इशू
नहीं है बट वह चीज आपको समझ में आनी चाहिए
तो आई होप कि आज की क्लास में सबको सब कुछ
क्लियर होगा यही यही प्रैक्टिकल्स हम कल
भी देखेंगे कि ये चीजें हो कैसी रही हैं
और इनको एनालाइज करना देखेंगे कि कैसे
इनको एनालाइज किया जाता है। कैसे पैकेट को
ट्रैफिक एनालिस कैसे जो हम बोल रहे हैं
ऑडियो को कैसे अट्रैक्ट किया जाता है।
कहां पर पासवर्ड कैसे डिक्रिप्ट किया जा
सकता है। पॉसिबल है। तो वह सारी चीजें हम
स्टेप बाय स्टेप बढ़ेंगे आगे।
काफी है आज के लिए।
आज के लिए काफी है बताओ।
आज के लिए काफी है। नेक्स्ट सेशन जल्दी आ
जाएगा। डोंट वरी। अब की बार लेट थोड़ी ना
हुआ सेशन। बताओ लेट हुआ है
क्योंकि शायद अब की बार सेशन लेट नहीं हुआ
है।
सेशन लेट हुआ है।
थोड़ा सा टाइम मुझे भी चाहिए होता ना रेडी
करने के लिए। इतनी सारी चीजें डिजाइन करने
में टाइम लगता है। मैं एआई यूज़ नहीं करता
डिजाइन करने के लिए। लेट हो गया।
एआई नहीं यूज़ करता मैं डिजाइन करने के
लिए। तो इसलिए यह सारी चीजें खुद से
डिजाइन करनी पड़ती हैं। तो
थोड़ा सा टाइम लगता है
बट
आई विल ट्राई थोड़ा सा और जल्दी हो पाएगा
तो मैं कोशिश करूंगा
लेकिन आप लोग आप लोग आते तो नहीं हो क्लास
में यार मैं कैसे करूं बताओ
किस चीज की मुझे तो यही नहीं पता कि आप
लोग क्या सीखने आए हो यार आप लोग खुद
क्लियर नहीं आप लोगों को
ओके ओके
जगत गुरु जी इट्स माय प्लेजर इफ यू थिंक
दैट वे
या आई एम फाइन ऑफिशियल
ओके थैंक यू
बाकी आप लोग आते तो हो नहीं क्लास में
इतने ज्यादा लोग पता नहीं ना ज्यादा शेयर
करते हो आप लोग ना इतने दिन तक तो
क्लास उतनी की उतनी थोड़ी ना रहनी चाहिए
इस पर बहुत सारे सेशन हैं कि अभी तो हमने
क्या किया स्टार्ट किया है देखते हैं
कितने आएंगे 4 5 3 2 1
देखते हैं कितने और आएंगे। बट इतना आएगा
कि आपको एक नॉलेज देके ही खत्म करेंगे इस
सेक्शन को भी।
देखो आपको वही पेन टेस्टिंग के लिए सीधी
सी बात है। आपके पास
वह चाहिए। बीच में आप उस नेटवर्क का पार्ट
होने चाहिए। पहली बात तो
उसके बाद एक बार विनोद वेट करो जब मैं
पूरा पढ़ा दूं तो समझ ले तब आपको समझ में
आएगा कि किस चीज के साथ आप डील करने जा
रहे हो।
समझ में आया? किस चीज के साथ आप डील करने
के लिए जा रहे हो। अब जिसकी आप बात कर रहे
हो सकता है कि इट इज मोर सिक्योर देन यू
कांट डू एनीथिंग। मैं आपको बताया था ना कि
अगर शिप भी इंक्रिप्टेड है और डाटा भी
इंक्रिप्टेड है। इन दैट केस यू कैन नॉट डू
एनीथिंग।
ओके तो किसी को कोई डाउट है क्लास से
रिलेटेड अदरवाइज सेशन को एंड करें बताओ।
अरे YouTube पे यार रिकॉर्डिंग क्यों नहीं
मिलती?
YouTube पर तो रिकॉर्डिंग अवेलेबल रहती
है।
YouTube पे अवेलेबल है ना यह तो
एक काम कीजिए आप एक काम करो गो टू मैं
आपको यही सर्च कर देता हूं। डेफोनिक्स
गो टू डेफ्रोनिक्स एकडमी और YouTube चैनल
पर जाना आपको
वो तो पहले हमारा यही वाला होगा तो एक काम
करोगे आप जब डेफ्रोनिक्स पे जाओगे यहां
सर्च करो
डेफ्रोनिक्स एकडमी और यहां पे आपको क्या
करना है डेफ्रोनिक्स चैनल पे जाना है
प्लेलिस्ट में जाना है और तो ये देखो
प्लेलिस्ट इतनी बड़ी है यहां पर मैं ये चल
रही डीएचई डेफोनिस एथिकल हैकर्स एसेंशियल
फुल प्लेलिस्ट आपके पास डे 55 अभी लाइव है
डे 54 तक आपको पूरी प्लेलिस्ट आपको देखने
को मिलेगी बिल्कुल जीरो से तो आप स्टार्ट
से स्टार्ट करना चाहते हो स्टार्ट से
कीजिए और लाइव को लाइव से करना चाहते हो
लाइव से कीजिए बट दिस इज अ कंप्लीट
प्लेलिस्ट जो आप फॉलो कर सकते हो
हां इसके पीपीटी नहीं कह सकता मैं इसके
ऊपर आर्टिकल्स मीडियम पे मिलेंगे
डेफिनेटली मिलेंगे 100%
चलिए फिर क्लास को एंड करते हैं। कुछ भी
नहीं है तो बाय-ब थैंक यू एंड गुड नाइट
एवरीवन एंड सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन। जल्दी
मिलते हैं। बाय-ब एंड गुड नाइट एवरीवन।